soyez vous-même les autres sont déjà
pris
le 30 septembre
1207 mais c'est l'un des plus grands des
plus grands ports de l'histoire de la
poésie Roumi
à l'âge de 19 ans
épousa une très jeune femme qui sera
assassinée trois ans plus tard
à l'âge de ses 40 ans
Romy fait connaissance
à son maître spirituel
qui sera lui aussi assassiné trois ans
plus tard
et oui
suite à ce tragédie
Romy consacre toute sa vie à la poésie
et principalement au thème de l'amour
ont été appréciés partout dans le monde
ce n'est pas priant que Romy a été
décrit comme le poète le plus lu et
l'écrivain le plus célèbre aux
États-Unis
j'en suis sûr que parmi vous il y a des
personnes qui connaissent remis
non
voyons
800 ans après il y a des gens
actuellement qui vivent le bonheur à
travers les écritures de roumain
800 ans après on est en 2022
ces derniers jours j'ai croisé une
personne dans le métro qui me raconta
son quotidien
à son réveil même pas 5 minutes il
tousse son téléphone
il est snober par les réseaux sociaux
il vit la vie et l'influence des autres
il n'a pas de vie pour lui vive sa
passion
c'est copier les autres suivre la
tendance à chaque fois
il préfère faire de la passion de
l'autre sa propre passion en
ignorant que l'autre qui fait des lives
l'autre qui fait ces vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est sa protection
donc pourquoi la prendre la passion de
l'autre et en fait notre passion
notre génération est confronté à un
problème qui est hyper hyper hyper
important c'est que la technologie la
technologie est devenue
la nouvelle forme d'esclavage on ne
prend plus la peine de réfléchir sur ce
qu'on aime vraiment mais on préfère
suivre la tendance de manière la vie de
l'autre
si prendre une décision à nous-mêmes
prendre une décision en nous-mêmes
normalement nous devons prendre nos
propres décisions sans l'influence des
autres mais on se rend compte que les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne persistent pas
les jours d'aujourd'hui croient que
vivre leur propre vie se base sur
l'influence des autres
alors
étant donné que chaque croit vie vivre
sa vie en copiant sur la vie des autres
le challenge pour notre génération c'est
de faire en sorte de façonner au monde
où chacun peut vivre sans être influencé
c'est la demande de créer sa propre
identité
d'incarner son propre valeur et de ne
pas se laisser déboussoler
l'une de mes histoires préférées c'était
en 2017 lorsque je me sentais perdu je
voulais comprendre la raison pour
laquelle les autres vivaient en harmonie
je voulais comprendre la raison pour
laquelle les autres étaient heureux ces
deux alors que j'ai abandonné tout ce
qui est réseaux sociaux
et je me suis focalisé
je me suis mis à travailler sur moi-même
j'ai abandonné tout ce qui m'était
inutile et je commence à faire des
investigations à lire les livres je
m'étais un petit peu déconnecté il y
avait même des amis qui ne comprenaient
pas ma décision mais il fallait le faire
j'ai découvert beaucoup de choses
j'ai découvert que durant l'Antiquité la
lecture n'était pas réservée à tout le
monde
j'espère que vous le savez
durant l'Antiquité la lecture était
réservée à l'élite tout le monde n'a
fait pas la possibilité de lire les gens
qui étaient censés lire c'était les gens
qui devaient guider les autres qui
devaient inspirer les autres c'est dès
lors que j'ai compris une chose
fondamentale c'est qu'il y a des livres
qui ne sont pas accessibles au grand
public
il y a des livres aujourd'hui vous les
trouvez pas gratuitement pourquoi parce
que ça libère
la différence entre cette génération là
et l'autre génération du passé on peut
dire ça c'est la culture générale au
moment donné il faut virer son téléphone
et ouvrir les livres
je vais vous donner un orage
qui est hyper hyper hyper important si
vous voulez cacher
quelque chose à un idiot
ne le mettez nulle part
mettez-les dans un livre
il n'ira jamais le chercher là-bas
c'est hyper important pourquoi parce que
les gens sont tellement
ils ont la flemme d'aller lire d'aller
chercher hier je parlais avec deux amis
et l'homme disait que
parfois il met en épreuve son enfant
aller va chercher au mot dans un
dictionnaire
mais c'est fabuleux
imaginez si la gratification immédiate
vous le donnez à votre enfant j'ai
besoin de ça tac tiens j'ai besoin de ça
mais je trouve que vous devez mettre en
épreuve vos enfants d'aller chercher
et j'adore une citation que je vais vous
partager de roomi que j'ai donc
j'apprécie ce que vous cherchez vous
cherchez
vous êtes d'accord avec moi
c'est tellement fabuleux
[Applaudissements]
et grâce aux livres je me suis j'ai fait
ce que j'ai à faire j'ai créé mon
micro-entreprise jette les entreprises
je fais ce que je vais faire
actuellement c'est grâce au livre et
actuellement je peux vous dire ce qui va
faire la différence entre génération là
et l'autre génération
c'est d'aller chercher parce que il
disait une chose importante
plus vous verrez dans le passé
mieux vous verrez le futur le passé le
présent le futur sont liés
donc ça dit potentiellement on peut
prédire ce qui va se passer dans 10 ans
dans 20 ans et aujourd'hui la lumière se
projeter sur moi
et je pense actuellement à l'un des plus
grands scientifiques du monde Thomas
nous avons eu l'ampoule électrique
et c'est pas par hasard parce que à un
moment donné si tu suis sa passion
tu incarne le changement et quand tu
incarnes le changement tu fais la
différence et grâce à sa passion Thomas
Edison nous a fourni ce qu'on a eu
aujourd'hui
et en 1989
timber nocely l'un des plus grands
scientifiques l'un des plus grands
informaticiens nous en fourni le
protocole www c'est grâce à lui
actuellement qu'on arrive à faire des
selfies qu'on arrive à partager des
vidéos sur Internet tout ça grâce à sa
passion
je pense aussi à Abraham Gall Abraham
Bell qui nous a fourni aussi le
téléphone c'est grâce à lui aujourd'hui
qu'on arrive à téléphoner et
actuellement un grand monsieur et en
train de travailler sur un projet
colossal pour le connaissez vous tous il
va amener les gens dans la planète Mars
qui est le masque et je me dis que ce
genre de personne
ils sont différents
ces genres de personnes ils sont aussi
ordinaires donc nous aussi si on veut
aujourd'hui incarner le changement
mettre dans de bonnes conditions cette
génération il va falloir suivre notre
passion et je suis sûr que dans ce
public il y a des parents qui
souhaiteraient avoir des enfants qui
ressemblent à Elon Musk
oui ou non
et dans ce monde
en vivant notre passion
on se rend compte qu'on peut vivre dans
un monde sans contrôle
à travers les livres on peut découvrir
beaucoup de choses
au monde sans loi ni contrôle un monde
sans limite ni frontières au monde où on
peut inspirer la génération future
ce que nous en ferons ne dépendra que de
vous
soyez vous-même les autres sont déjà
pris
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]